Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Nicoletta Pedrana
L'etica non può accontentarsi
di essere solo giusta.
Ma deve essere, anche, efficace.
È facile intuire le ragioni
di questa affermazione:
l'etica ha a che fare
con l'ambiente malato;
con persone che soffrono,
con popoli che soffrono.
Ed è chiaro che non bastano
le buone intenzioni:
i problemi di chi sta male vanno risolti.
Ecco perché l'etica deve essere efficace.
Ma c'è una seconda ragione
per cui l'etica è necessario
che sia efficace:
noi non possiamo continuare a pensare
che l'etica sia prerogativa
di pochi eroi masochisti,
che si immolano
sull'altare dei buoni ideali.
Noi dobbiamo rendere l'etica
accessibile a tutti,
e un modo per renderla accessibile
è quella di renderla conveniente.
Queste riflessioni sono riflessioni
che non c'erano, all'inizio:
sono riflessioni che abbiamo maturato
grazie al percorso con GOEL in Calabria.
Un percorso che nasce nel 2003,
e che oggi continua
e sta ottenendo
dei risultati significativi.
GOEL oggi è un gruppo cooperativo,
formato da: 12 cooperative sociali;
due cooperative di conferimento agricolo;
due associazioni di volontariato;
una fondazione; 30 aziende.
E stiamo crescendo sempre di più
in tutta questa regione,
splendida e meravigliosa,
che è la Calabria.
La Calabria è una regione che soffre,
la regione del sud Italia
che soffre di più.
Sapete che i dati, gli indicatori,
sono davvero molto problematici:
arriviamo al 50%
di disoccupazione giovanile.
GOEL è nato nella Locride,
e nella Locride si arriva al 60/70%
di disoccupazione giovanile.
Ma sapete, anche,
che uno dei mali della
nostra terra, della Calabria,
è la ndrangheta:
la mafia nata, sviluppatasi
a partire dalla Calabria
ma che oggi è presente in tutto il mondo,
e che in qualche modo ha risucchiato
le energie vitali di questa terra
e ha impedito lo sviluppo
della nostra terra.
Quando, nel 2003,
abbiamo iniziato con GOEL,
avevamo - e continuiamo ad avere,
anche oggi - un obiettivo ambizioso:
cambiare le cose in Calabria,
innescare percorsi
di riscatto e di cambiamento.
È chiaro: un popolo non lo si cambia
dall'esterno, è il popolo che si cambia.
Però il cambiamento può innescarlo
a talune condizioni.
È chiaro che, quando siamo partiti,
eravamo ben consci
che nel nostro percorso avremmo trovato
ostacoli grandi e forti
come la 'ndrangheta.
Che non è sola:
perché la 'ndrangheta, in Calabria,
si è alleata con un reticolo
di massonerie deviate,
che hanno consentito alla 'ndrangheta
di infiltrarsi nei gangli dello Stato.
La ndrangheta non si è mai sognata,
come Cosa Nostra, di sfidare lo Stato:
la 'ndrangheta ha preferito
infiltrarlo, lo Stato.
E non solo: le massonerie deviate
hanno consentito alla 'ndrangheta, anche,
di reinvestire i loro soldi
in giro per il mondo.
Oggi la 'ndrangheta è una realtà criminale
con una stima di giro d'affari annuo
tra i 50 e i 60 miliardi di euro all'anno:
il bilancio di un piccolo stato europeo.
È l'importatore numero uno
della cocaina in Europa.
E comincia ad essere
un pericolo serio per la democrazia,
non solo per la Calabria
ma in tutti i posti
in cui si sta infiltrando,
in Italia ma anche all'estero.
Allora, cosa poteva fare
un gruppo di cooperative sociali,
e di imprese sociali,
che aveva questo obiettivo ambizioso
di innescare il riscatto e il cambiamento?
Goel è una parola biblica:
vuol dire il riscattatore,
la riscattatrice.
E l'idea che ci è venuta fin dall'inizio
è stata quella di dire:
noi non possiamo continuare
ad attaccare questa mafia
solo dal punto di vista morale.
Anche perché vedevamo che, nel territorio,
la 'ndrangheta si legittimava
dal punto di vista economico.
Loro non negavano,
non negano di essere cattivi:
anzi, ne fanno un vanto.
Detto ciò, nel territorio,
a tutto quello che gira
a livello economico
in qualche modo noi ci siamo in mezzo.
Una grande falsità,
perché se oggi hanno
un ruolo economico così importante
è perché hanno tagliato le gambe
a chiunque stava provando a portare
economia e sviluppo in altro modo.
Tuttavia, queste sono le menzogne
che loro portano avanti.
Da un lato abbiamo scelto
di demistificare queste grandi bugie,
raccontando quello che è evidente, poi,
sennò non si spiegherebbe
come la mafia oggi considerata
più potente al mondo
abbia prodotto l'ultima regione in Europa.
La verità è che là dove
la 'ndrangheta attecchisce,
là dove la mafia attecchisce,
risucchia, avvelena,
fa seccare il territorio.
Dall'altro lato, però,
ci aspettava un compito
molto più impegnativo:
legittimare l'etica.
Che l'etica sia giusta, lo pensiamo tutti:
probabilmente, anche gli 'ndranghetisti.
Che l'etica sia capace
di dar da mangiare alle persone,
che l'etica possa essere
l'asse portante dello sviluppo
di una regione come la Calabria,
be', discutiamone:
non so quanti di noi
siano realmente convinti di questo.
Allora, GOEL è diventato
il plastico in miniatura
di cosa potrebbe diventare la Calabria,
se puntasse sull'etica.
Avete presente quando gli architetti
fanno le grandi opere?
Fanno il plastico in miniatura.
E ci siamo messi a realizzare attività,
non solo in ambito sociale:
noi abbiamo attività
con i minori a rischio,
attività nell'accoglienza dei migranti -
perché siamo convinti
che l'accoglienza dei migranti
non è solo giusta, ma è una grande
opportunità di sviluppo.
Abbiamo operato nella sanità,
perché siamo convinti che l'etica
fa funzionare la sanità,
nell'ambito psichiatrico.
Ma abbiamo dato una mano
a quelle donne e quegli uomini coraggiosi
che in Calabria dicono
di no alla 'ndrangheta.
E sono tanti, a dispetto
dei luoghi comuni.
E sono anche, e soprattutto,
persone, imprenditori,
piccoli imprenditori a livello locale.
E nella maggior parte dei casi,
queste donne e questi uomini coraggiosi,
quando si ribellano alla ndrangheta
mettono in conto di correre dei rischi.
Quello che non calcolano
è che la 'ndrangheta, spesso,
ha la forza economica
di far fallire la loro impresa.
Allora, noi abbiamo avviato
delle iniziative
che cercano di dimostrare
che non hanno fatto la scelta perdente,
ma hanno fatto la scelta vincente
anche dal punto di vista economico.
In ambito turistico,
abbiamo messo su un tour operator:
si chiama "I viaggi del Goel".
Facciamo turismo responsabile
con i beni confiscati,
e con i proprietari di ristoranti,
e di alberghi, e di strutture ricettive
che si sono ribellati alla 'ndrangheta.
Abbiamo recuperato l'antica tradizione
della tessitura a mano
e ne abbiamo fatto il primo marchio
di moda etica di fascia alta in Italia.
E poi, l'agroalimentare.
Ed è l'attività su cui
voglio soffermarmi con voi.
A un certo punto,
arrivano degli agricoltori della Locride
e della Piana di Gioia Tauro,
e ci chiedono aiuto
perché vengono continuamente aggrediti
da parte della 'ndrangheta.
Incendi, danneggiamenti,
pascolo nei campi coltivati:
uno stillicidio di aggressioni,
con lo scopo di portare
all'esasperazione l'agricoltore
e poi portarlo al cospetto
del capobastone locale,
per chiedere protezione.
Questi che vengono a chiederci aiuto
sono agricoltori che non avrebbero
mai abbassato la testa;
però erano stanchi di subire,
però erano stanchi di continuare
a prendere le botte.
E allora, noi abbiamo fatto
quello che sappiamo fare:
li abbiamo messi insieme,
abbiamo fatto la prima cooperativa
di aziende agricole
che si ribellano alla 'ndrangheta.
Ne abbiamo fatto
anche un marchio, "GOEL Bio";
e poi siamo andati a vedere
cosa accadeva a livello economico
in queste aziende agricole.
E abbiamo trovato
una situazione disastrosa.
Pensate che dieci anni fa,
quando abbiamo fatto nascere
il ramo agricolo del gruppo GOEL,
le arance a questi produttori
venivano pagate
tra cinque e dieci centesimi al chilo.
Parlo del prezzo all'origine:
ai cancelli dell'azienda, si suol dire.
Chiaramente, capite che quando ti pagano
le arance cinque, dieci centesimi al chilo
tu hai due possibilità:
o le lasci marcire, e non le raccogli;
oppure tiri il collo agli operai,
li schiavizzi nei campi
per provare a stare in quel prezzo da fame
che ti danno gli intermediari
della grande distribuzione.
Allora abbiamo rifatto tutto daccapo:
abbiamo organizzato la filiera,
l'abbiamo innalzata
al livello qualitativo -
tutto biologico, rigorosamente;
ci siamo dotati di nostri centri
di confezionamento,
di nostri centri di trasformazione;
ci siamo dotati di una nostra
struttura commerciale:
niente grossisti, niente intermediari.
Da noi, a chi vende i nostri frutti.
Oggi, i produttori di GOEL Bio -
qualche settimana fa
si sono visti insieme,
e hanno stabilito qual è
il prezzo delle arance:
50 centesimi al chilo.
50 centesimi non è, solo,
cinque volte dieci centesimi:
cinquanta centesimi è il prezzo più alto
mai pagato per le arance in Calabria.
Vuoi vedere che, per la prima volta,
mettersi contro la 'ndrangheta conviene,
e riesci a prendere il prezzo più alto
per le arance in Calabria?
Allora, a partire da questo,
abbiamo continuato sull'etica:
insieme ai produttori abbiamo stabilito
un codice di condotta
perché a nessuno venga in mente
di sfruttare i lavoratori nei campi.
Controlli a sorpresa durante la raccolta;
10.000 euro di multa
di sanzione per danno d'immagine
se si becca un operaio in nero,
e la denuncia all'Ispettorato del Lavoro.
Poi abbiamo messo su l'economia circolare,
dimostrando che più l'etica aumentava
più aumentavano i guadagni
dignitosi per tutti:
per gli imprenditori, per i lavoratori.
Questa dinamica è stata molto importante,
perché ha ridato fiducia alle persone,
e ha cominciato a rendere l'etica
accessibile a tutti.
Fino al punto tale da venire
alla resa dei conti con la 'ndrangheta,
e con gli attacchi della 'ndrangheta.
Sì, perchè la 'ndrangheta ci ha attaccato:
è chiaro, lo avrete già capito.
Noi, fino a qualche anno fa,
avevamo in media da due
a tre aggressioni all'anno.
Finché, a un certo punto,
non ci è venuto in mente di fare
una cosa un po' matta, un po' pazza.
E ci è venuta dopo
un bruttissimo attentato
subito da una nostra azienda agricola.
Questa azienda agricola,
a Monasterace Marina,
si è vista bruciare
tutto il capannone, il trattore.
Gli hanno incenerito tutto:
più di 100.000 euro di danni.
E solo questa azienda agricola ha ricevuto
sette aggressioni in sette anni.
Bene: da lì, una volta che abbiamo visto
che c'erano diverse persone
che ci avevano dato dei soldi
per riparare il danno,
abbiamo fatto una riflessione,
ci siamo detti:
ma che cos'è che la 'ndrangheta vuole
quando attacca un'azienda,
una nostra azienda
ma un'azienda anche del territorio?
Direte: vuole fare un danno economico.
E avete ragione.
Ma in realtà, vuole fare
anche un danno qui
e un danno qui, alle persone
che stanno a guardare.
Perché sapete qual è la frase
che il giorno dopo l'attentato
si sente dire, nei nostri paesini?
La gente dice: "Lo vedi?
Qui non cambierà mai nulla:
è stato così, e sarà sempre così.
Tocca solo andarsene."
Allora, noi abbiamo detto:
questa si chiama depressione sociale.
Vedete, la depressione sociale
è una precondizione di dominio.
Un popolo depresso tu lo controlli bene;
un popolo che spera
è un popolo indomabile.
Ma guardate che questo
non l'ha capito solo la 'ndrangheta.
Allora, ci è venuto in mente
un'idea un po' pazza.
Abbiamo detto: "Da adesso in poi,
ogni volta che ci colpiranno
noi organizzeremo una festa,
e la chiameremo Festa della Ripartenza".
La "Festa della Ripartenza",
funziona così:
coinvolgiamo la comunità locale
attorno alla vittima colpita,
poi coinvolgiamo l'opinione pubblica
nazionale, attorno alla vittima colpita.
E tutto questo innesca
una serie di reazioni
solidali, di vicinanza.
Allora c'è quello che dice alla vittima
"Ti aiuto a ricostruire";
c'è l'altro che gli dice
"Ti aiuto a vendere i prodotti".
E noi lasciamo che queste conseguenze
positive si dispieghino.
Dopo due o tre mesi,
andiamo nelle tv locali
e ci rivolgiamo alla 'ndrangheta,
pubblicamente.
Quella prima volta,
con quel primo attentato,
andammo nelle tv locali e dicemmo:
voi 'ndranghetisti,
che avete bruciato il capannone
della nostra azienda agricola:
bene, vogliamo darvi il risultato
di quello che avete combinato.
Questa azienda aveva un capannone vecchio,
e ora ha un capannone nuovo;
questa azienda aveva un trattore vecchio,
e ora ha un trattore nuovo;
la precedente stagione
aveva venduto pochi agrumi,
adesso ne ha venduti tanti.
Complimenti: se è questo
quello che volevate fare,
ci siete riusciti.
Anzi, vi diciamo: continuate
a colpirci, se volete,
perché più ci colpirete
più grazie alla fiducia,
e al consenso popolare,
noi diventeremo più forti.
Bene:
siamo arrivati a tre
Feste della Ripartenza,
e poi sono andati in tilt.
È successo qualcosa di inaudito,
di inaspettato, di incredibile:
è da quattro anni che non ci fanno
danneggiamenti seri.
Il primo tempo della battaglia
per la libertà e per il cambiamento
l'abbiamo vinto noi.
E tutto questo vi fa vedere
in una maniera plastica,
e in una maniera molto concreta,
quanto l'etica,
nel momento in cui si organizza,
nel momento in cui diventa innovativa,
nel momento in cui genera speranza,
ci dà la forza di poter cambiare le cose.
Noi abbiamo un potere grande:
di poter cambiare le cose,
se corriamo il rischio
di metterci insieme,
di sudare sangue col cervello
per generare innovazione,
perché se l'etica non è accessibile
è solo colpa del nostro sforzo.
E noi dobbiamo fare in modo
che sempre di più questo accada,
perché così cambierà il mondo.
(Applausi)